one thing I want to ask you before I
wrap this up is if I sent you a picture
of me would it go oh behind you you know
yeah I see you've got Obama would if I
sent you a list of my 8 by 10 my showbiz
8 by 10 and I framed it would it be
butwait would it be autographed to me or
no
I can autograph it if you want that
tends to lessen the value but oh it does
but there's a space right over your
shoulder where big picture of me would
confuse everybody just a big smiling
picture of me can I tell you something
in retrospect what I'm so wishing right
now I'm so wishing I had had that
therefore this entire conversation and
we had made no mention of it FedEx that
to you well this has been a delight I
really always love talking to you
likewise Connie you're very cool I like
I look forward to seeing you at 400
pounds I'm I will be there too yeah
that's gonna be great we can shop
together one of those really called big
and small stores correct we'll go to a
big and tall store together that'll be
nice I am looking forward to the
Hollywood red carpets right after this
thing is over and all everyone looking
very healthy let's just say free yeah so
face out full faced I want to make sure
that I mentioned again the NRDC the NRDC
the Natural Resources Defense Council
which is an incredibly important
critical organization nationally and
internationally when it comes to saving
the earth well god bless you I don't say
that lightly
I say it's a very few people but I bow
to you I doubt you Coenen god bless you
too and I will get you a very overly
large picture of me for the background
for your future interviews just to
confuse people okay you know what I kind
of would love it if you do that don't
don't forget to do that I know
all right take care hey thank you so
much for doing this thank you for having
me it's always a pleasure
all right go eat some cake batter okay
I'll see you later bye